[MUSIC PLAYING]
SEAN: Thank you all for taking
some time out of your day.
We're going to start by looking
at the RMarkdown document.
And how we can use R and
Python together inside
of that document with
some special new magic
that's available in the
latest versions of RStudio.
We'll also talk about how
once we finish that document,
it can be published and
shared in a reproducible way.
So that others can view
it and perhaps, you
might introduce some
lightweight automation.
We'll look briefly at
how a similar outcome can
be achieved with
cheaper notebooks using
shared infrastructure.
And then, we'll talk
about how the model we're
creating in this
document can actually
be put into place so
that decisions can
be made based on that model.
And we'll look at
how you can maybe
do that with an
interactive app or there is
something like a RESTful API.
And then finally, we'll
talk about how those APIs
and applications can
also be developed
using some of the new options
inside of the RStudio toolset.
So we'll go ahead
and jump in and set
a little bit of context.
I am using RStudio on a server.
And so that means I'm
going to access RStudio
through a web browser.
And there's a couple of really
nice benefits to doing this.
The first is that I have more
resources available to me
than I would on my laptop.
And specifically, if I go
in to start a new session,
you'll see we're taking
advantage of a tool called
Kubernetes that allows me
to demand to specify what
resources I want for this work.
Another benefit of
[INAUDIBLE] a server
is that it means everyone
on my team, Lou and myself,
are speaking from
a common playbook.
And in this case,
we're explicitly
defining our environment
through a Docker image
where our session
is going to run.
Even if you're not using
Kubernetes or Docker,
by having your work
on a server, everyone
has a common home,
which helps make
collaboration a lot easier.
And then finally, because
we're on a server,
we're a lot closer
to our data, which
means our work can scale
in an easier fashion.
Now, in a moment I'll be
jumping into RStudio ID.
But while I'm here I
just want to point out
that one of the
things we've done
in the last year for
multilingual teams
is added the ability
for other editing tools
to be accessed from
this same interface.
So it's almost like
a Workbench, where
you can pick up the right
tool from that Workbench
regardless of what language
your current project demands.
And that means for multilingual
data science teams,
everyone has all
those benefits I just
described that the
common playbook,
regardless of what
editor they're using.
And for IT, it's really nice
to have this common front
door or these
different environments
are going to be accessed.
So we'll go ahead and
jump into RStudio.
And at this point,
I want to point out
that everything you're going
to see inside of RStudio IDE
even though I'm using
the RStudio server
is going to be available in
any flavor of the RStudio IDE.
So whether you're using the
open-source desktop or RStudio
Server open source or the
professional product like I am,
you'll have access to
the interoperability
that we're about to get through.
So to set the stage
just a little bit more,
I'm doing my work here inside
of an RMarkdown document.
If you haven't seen
RMarkdown before,
it's basically a format
where I can combine pros.
So what I'm thinking along with
my code and then the output
of my code.
But what's new in the
latest version of RStudio
is something that we're
calling the visual editor.
And what that means is that even
though I'm editing an RMarkdown
document, on the fly I'm
getting a live rendering of what
this document looks like.
And so that means I can do
things a little bit easier
than I used to.
So, for example, if I
needed to put in a table,
I could insert a
table really quickly.
I can add Markdown
to that table and it
will be rendered on-demand.
I can even do things like
insert citations or emojis.
And so I can use all these
different tools inside
of the visual editor.
And whatever I'm doing
is going to show up
as a real-time preview.
And the reason why I
think this is so important
is that regardless of what
language you're working from,
ultimately, a data scientist's
key job is to communicate.
And so being able
to write effectively
in a tool that
supports really rich
technical communication is vital
for any type of data scientist.
And I found that
this visual editor
makes things that
used to be challenging
for that type of technical
communication really easy.
One of my favorites
is I can go in here
and actually insert an image.
I don't have to worry
about figuring out
where that image lives on disk.
And I can even resize
it interactively.
So we hope that regardless
of what language,
this visual editor is going to
give you a head start as you're
writing down what you're
thinking and documenting
your process.
And it really combines the best
worlds of a Jupyter Notebook
[INAUDIBLE] IDE and RMarkdown.
And if you haven't
seen this before,
inside the latest version of
RStudio, all you need to do
is click this button in the
upper right hand corner.
And what that then does
is flip us back and forth
between the plain
text source code that
is still available here
perfect for version control
and that pre-rendered
view of the document.
All right.
So that's where
we're doing our work.
It is inside of
this visual editor.
What are we going to do?
We have a made-up
data science exercise.
And so like most data
science exercises,
we're going to start by
pulling in some data.
And this data is
coming from a database.
And again, something that
we're excited about regardless
of what language you use is
the ability within RStudio
to seamlessly manage
connections to databases.
And so here I have a connection
to a database called content.
There's a number of different
tables inside of it.
And without switching to
a different sequel editor,
I can really easily preview the
schema of this database table
and even preview some of
the records if I want.
So I have this database
and I'm starting out
by writing some code
that's going to operate
within the database to
do some basic transforms.
And so if you haven't seen
this before, using dplyr,
you can write R code.
Then that R code actually
gets executed as a sequel.
And so that's what's
going on here.
So we're creating some
data that we're then
going to do an analysis on.
So let's take a quick
look at that data.
Essentially, we have
spatial-temporal data.
And so we're looking
at bike-share data
from the D.C. area.
So those bike shares,
if you've ever
been walking around the city
and you want to rent a bike,
you can usually find a
station with bikes lined up
and then you pay
some money to be
able to ride the bike around.
And so the data that
we have is how many
bikes were available
at any given
station at any point in time.
So we have this time series
of bikes that are available,
then we also have a
spatial component of where
those bikes were located.
So it's a pretty cool data set.
And what we want to
try to do is forecast
into the future
for a given station
how many bikes
might be available.
And say, if you've
commute home at 5:00 PM,
is there going to be a
bike there that I can take?
And so we'll get started
by doing that in R.
And the first thing
that we're going to do
is create a test and
training data set.
And because we're working
with time-series data,
it's really important
that we don't accidentally
use the future to
predict the past.
And so, in R we've created,
a test and training data set,
where the training data
set sequentially occurs
before the test data set.
And now, that we have
these two things,
we can go ahead and
build our model.
And I'm using a new R package
or an ecosystem of R packages
called tidy models.
There's a lot of
great resources online
if you want to dive
into modeling an R.
But essentially, what
this set of packages
is allowing us to do is
pre-process our data.
And so, we have here
latitude and longitude.
That's the spatial element.
We have the date and time.
That's the temporal element.
But we've used some
preprocessing tricks
to create a factor for
the day of the week
and also add some information
about whether a given
day was a holiday.
So you have a nice rich
data set to do modeling on.
And then, the first
thing that we might do
is create a model in R.
And so to do that, again, within
this tidy model's ecosystem
and essentially
creating a workflow.
That's going to take our
model preprocessing along
with this gradient
boosted engine
and fit a simple
regression model.
So we can go ahead and do that.
And if we look at
the results here,
we have a predicted
number of bikes
along with the actual
number of bikes, kind
of what we'd expect.
And we can evaluate
how our prediction did.
So one thing that we can do
for that quick evaluation
is plot the prediction
versus the reality.
And if our model is really
good, all of our data points
would fall along
this y equals x line,
where predictions match reality.
You can see, we have quite
the variance from that line.
We could look at the R
squared value of our model
and see that it's not very good.
That's why I'm paid to give
webinars and not fit models
but this hopefully,
gives you a sense
of what your workflow might
start to look like an R. We can
even because this is
a tree-based model.
Look at feature
importance, and so you
can see that our
model is emphasizing
the location of our
bike share station
and not putting as much weight
on some of those factors
that we create.
So we have this iffy model in
R. What do we want to do next?
Well, we could try a
lot of different things
to improve our model.
One thing we might want
to do is try something
from the Python ecosystem.
And so that's where the
heart of this webinar
begins which is,
how are we going
to interoperate Python and R
inside of the same context?
Well, the first
thing that we'll do
is create a Python code chunk.
And inside of that
Python code chunk,
one of the things that we're
going to do right after that
is import some packages.
So go ahead and add the code
to bring in these packages.
And we can do a quick
sanity check here
to run the code
chunk and it appears
that we have these packages
loaded inside of Python.
Now, I can already see in
the chat that many of you
are asking how is
Python managed?
Where are these
packages coming from?
Those are really
great questions.
So in the latest
version of RStudio,
you can use a project
or global option
to specify what Python
interpreter should
be used in the
context where you're
mixing R and Python together.
And so for this project, I've
created a virtual environment
and I have selected
and told RStudio to use
that virtual environment.
They can see that
RStudio is actually
aware of the multitude
of Python installs
that are available
on this server.
And that's one of those
benefits of working on a server
is that if Lou and I were
collaborating together
we'd have this common
understanding of what Python
installations are available.
So that's where the Python
engine is coming from.
The Python packages themselves
are coming from a tool called
RStudio package manager.
So in our case, our
server is not online.
Here, we have some
sensitive data
that lives in our environment.
So we're not able to go
reach out to the internet.
So instead package manager
acts as this intermediary,
where we can install Python
packages from a specifically
governed mirror of PyPI.
And so that's what
you're looking at here--
I can search for packages,
I can see information
about those packages,
how to install them,
what they depend on.
But something really
special about this mirror
is that it has a
safety net that allows
me to time travel as well.
And so if I ever
got into a situation
where my Python
environment wasn't working,
I could go backward
or forward in time
to reinstall packages from a
specific point in the past.
So that's where these
packages are coming from.
Let's go ahead and
start writing some code.
And this is where I think
things get really magical.
Because within this
Python code chunk,
inside of the
RMarkdown document,
I actually have
access to everything
that I've done up
until this point in R.
And you can actually
see the idea here
is helping me autocomplete
some of the objects that
are attributes of this special
R object that are available.
And so what does that mean?
Well, I'm going to
cheat a little bit
and grab some code that
I've written ahead of time.
We'll just put this
inside of our code chunk
and then I can walk
you through it.
So the first thing I'm
doing, because we're
going to fit this
model in Python,
is to load some
training and test data.
But you can see that I'm
not starting from scratch.
I'm using this magic R
object to actually pull
in the training and test
data that I already created.
And then, I can use that
as a jumping-off point
for fitting my model.
And so we're going to do a
little bit of pre-processing
with pandas and then
we're going to use
some functions from scikit-learn
to fit another type of model.
And one of the things that
are really interesting
and why we might
jump into Python here
is that scikit-learning has
native support for time series
cross-validation.
So remember, I said we can't use
the future to predict the past.
Scikit-learn knows how
to handle that even
in the case where you're
doing a whole bunch
of cross-validation thing.
And so that's what we're doing
here to fit in SVR our model.
I can go ahead and run
this Python code chunk
and we can take a
look at the results.
All right.
So train results
that mean, that's
the mean of our cross-validation
r-squared value?
And you can see,
whoo, it's really bad.
OK.
So I'm not a great
Python model fitter.
But hopefully, you get the idea
that we can really seamlessly
reuse things back and forth.
And you might have noticed
a couple of other things
that the idea is
doing to help me
with this Python development.
So one of the things
that I briefly mentioned
is that autocomplete.
And so say we wanted to
use a different model
from scikit-learn.
You can see the
idea is providing me
with all the different
options that are available,
all the attributes and
methods of these objects,
and the help for those methods
that arguments that they take
are also all going to
be available in the IDE
with the rich auto-completion
that you'd expect.
The other thing
that will point out
is if we look at
the environment pane
when we switch to
the Python context,
we actually got a Python
environment Explorer as well.
And so these objects that I'm
creating inside of Python,
you can actually see them and
explore them inside of the IDE
and I could even
preview them as well.
So this becomes
a really rich way
to interactively do your
work and debug problems.
And we can see that even things
like the filter capability
inside of the IDE as well as
sort work for these Python
objects.
I can also switch at
any time back and forth
between R and Python
because the two
ecosystems are coexisting
together inside
of this notebook.
Speaking of which,
there's one last trick
that I want to show you.
So I fit this Python model and
I have some Python predictions.
What if I then wanted to go
and do some further analysis?
Well, you saw how I can reduce
R objects in the Python context,
but I can do the same
thing inside of R.
So inside of R there's this
magic object called py that
gives me access to
everything that I've created
so far in the Python space.
And so I can go ahead
and use that object
to do something like this.
So I grab some code
from my cheat sheet,
place it in this chunk.
I'm essentially taking the
Python model predictions
and plotting them with ggplot2.
And you can see
a little bit here
why our model fit is so bad.
It's because we're not capturing
nearly any of the variance that
is going on inside of our data.
All right.
So we've fit this model that
combines R and Python together
inside of a notebook.
What do we do now?
Well, at RStudio,
we're big believers
that you should share your data
science work early and often.
This is the best way for
people with domain knowledge
or stakeholders to validate
that you're on the right path.
And so one way to do that
that's really powerful
is through publishing.
And within RStudio,
we can publish--
you see this blue icon here--
and we can publish to
a number of places.
But within a team
enterprise setting,
our recommendation is to
publish to RStudio Connect.
And so I'll go
ahead and do that.
You can see the ID
identifies my dependencies.
And what happens
when I click Publish
is that a reproducible
unit is created here
that contains not
only my code, but also
things like the version of
R, the version of Python,
the different packages that
I need to reliably reproduce
this document.
And so I'll go and
show you the end
result here on
RStudio Connect, which
is that same rendered notebook.
So we have kind of
all the information
that I have been working up to
this point, but in the context
where I can easily
share it with others.
So I can specify who
should be able to see this.
And because it's that
reproducible unit,
at any point, I can reliably
refresh this document
to regenerate the results,
or I could do something
like set up a schedule.
So my data might
change over time,
but I want this notebook to
render on a regular basis.
And I can set all of that up
because the dependencies are
intertwined in a reproducible
unit with this document.
Now you might be
thinking, that's
great if you're RStudio user,
which probably most of you are.
But what about my colleagues
on the Python side?
Well, the same option is
available for sharing your work
early and often if you're
coming from Python.
And so I want to quickly show
you what that looks like.
In the RStudio IDE we click
that blue Publish button.
And inside of Jupyter
Notebooks, you
can click that blue
Publish button as well.
But I want to show you
a slightly different way
that you can quickly and
easily share your content.
And that's to import content
from a system like Git.
So what I have here
is a Git repository.
And that Git repository
contains all of the example code
we've been talking about today.
And it's a public
repository, so you
can go ahead and play around
with this as well if you like.
What I'm going to do is
take this Git repository
and tell our RStudio Connect
to import that content.
And so I have different branches
that I can choose between,
and then this
repository has a number
of different directories.
I'll go ahead and import
the Jupyter Notebook.
I'll give it a title here.
And what happens when we
import this content is
the same thing that we saw
an interactive publishing.
The environment this content
depends upon is recreated.
So I have a reproducible unit
of work around my notebook.
If I go and open
up that notebook,
I can see the results.
So I can share this, even
with a non-technical user, who
might be intimidated by the
standard Jupyter Notebook
interface.
Here, they just have a
really clean HTML document
that they can read.
And a data scientist
can specify who
should be able to
see this content,
but also do those
same things I was
talking about for
scheduling or re-rendering
the content on demand.
So we have our notebooks.
We've shared them
early and often.
That's great.
We've gotten this
domain feedback.
And maybe we iterate
a couple of times
and really improve that model.
What do we do with that?
How do we ensure that the
model is actually being
used to generate decisions?
That's kind of the key task
of the data science team.
Well, there's two ways that we
think about this at RStudio.
One is to influence how decision
makers are making decisions
through your model.
And a great way to
do that is through
interactive applications.
So many of you might be familiar
with tools like Shiny, which
allow you to do
that in R. But we've
worked hard in the last year to
ensure that multilingual teams
have that same capability.
So what you're looking at
here is a Dash application,
which is an interactive
application written in Python.
And what this application
is going to allow us to do
is help stakeholders
understand our model.
So they can come
in here and click
through different
stations and see
the forecast and the
location of the station.
So it's a pretty simple app.
But hopefully, it kind
of gets your wheels
turning that even if you're
a Python data scientist
or you work with
Python data scientists,
they have the same ability
to impact decisions
by creating interactive content.
And we see examples of that
with Dash, with Streamlit,
with Bokeh, with a wide
variety of interactive Python
frameworks that are supported
through the RStudio stack.
So that's how you might
go about influencing
a person with your model.
But what if you need
to use your model
to make a whole bunch
of automated decisions,
or if you need to influence
not a person, but a service?
One way that's common
to solve that problem
is by creating an API.
And again, there's options for
doing this in R and Python.
So on the R side, we
have tools like Plumber.
On the Python side, we
have tools like Flask.
And both of these can
be shared just as easily
through RStudio Connect.
And so I'll just quickly show
you what that API might entail.
Again, we have all
of the same controls.
And so we can look at the
logs of this Plumber API.
We could do things like scale.
If we know we're going to
have thousands of requests
to this API at the
same time, we can
specify how we want the system
to handle those requests.
But at the end of the day,
the idea is pretty simple.
It's that anyone can
come in and place
a parameter of your model--
In this case, we're
specifying the station
that we want to make
a prediction for
and the time horizon that we
want to make a prediction for--
and then those inputs
are passed to our model
and the results are returned.
So here, we have the
results of our forecast.
But as you can see, that
passing of inputs and outputs
is done in a way that
machines can understand.
So here, we have
the output in JSON.
And just above that,
we have the request
that our interactive exploration
of this API would generate.
So other systems or services
or software engineers
can take advantage of
your model at scale.
All right.
So we've covered
quite a bit of ground.
We've talked about how to make
these models through notebooks.
We've talked about
the different ways
that you can
enhance those models
and put them into production,
but didn't actually show
you the code for either that
Dash application or this API.
So that's the last thing
that I wanted to do
is talk a little bit about
how you can get started
writing in this type of code.
And so if I go back
to the RStudio IDE,
if you're an R user,
my recommendation
is to just click
New File, and you'll
see a bunch of
options, two of which
are Shiny web applications
and Plumber APIs.
So those are going to get
you started with creating
either web apps or APIs.
If you're a Python user,
inside of the RStudio
stack we looked at
Jupyter Notebooks.
But if you want to do
this type of coding
for APIs or applications,
you're probably
going to need a little
bit more robust editor.
And you can use either
JupyterLab or the VS Code
for that purpose.
If I open up Visual Studio
code, the last thing
I want to show you here is
just how easy that deployment
of an API or an application is.
So inside of the code
again, I'm working off
of that shared common
Python environment.
So it's easy for me to
collaborate and automatically
get the right Python environment
as all my colleagues.
I have my code here
for a Dash application.
And then all I need
to do to deploy
is use a utility that we've
created called RSConnect.
So this is just a Python package
that you can install really,
wherever you're
writing Python code.
And it has commands to help
you then take that Python code
and wrap it up in that
reproducible context.
So for example, I'll do
RSConnect deploy Dash
to a server called Dev.
And it's going to run
through and identify
all the dependencies
of this application
and then give me the
link to the deployed app.
And if we follow
that link, you'll
see the exact same
bike share application
we were looking at before.
So to recap, we covered
quite a bit of ground.
We created that document using
R in Python and some really cool
RStudio magic.
That document was shared
in a reproducible way.
We talked about how
Jupyter Notebook users can
do the same type of
early and often sharing,
and then how we can use that
model to impact decisions,
either through apps or APIs.
And finally, how you might
go about writing those things
using some of the new
features in RStudio Workbench.
With that, I will
hand things over
to Lou, who's going
to bring us home.
And then we'll have the Q&amp;A.
LOU: Thank you, Sean.
That was great.
So, while Sean was talking,
I was taking a look a lot
of the questions
coming in via Slido.
There are a number
of questions there
that have been
upvoted, some of which
that Sean covered a lot of
that material in his demo
after those questions came in.
But we'll get to as
many of those as we can.
So, Sean showed off a number
of different things here.
For the data
scientist, he showed
how you can use these two
languages closely together
without a lot of overhead.
So the data scientists
can use each language
for their own strengths.
Also illustrated some
of the different IDEs
that can be used,
allowing data scientists
to use their preferred IDE
again, making that easy.
And we now support in
addition to the RStudio IDE
of course, Jupyter and VS Code.
Visual editing of R
Markdown is a great advance.
Again, making the
user experience,
the developer experience for
data scientists much easier.
And to answer one of the
questions in the Q&amp;A,
that visual Markdown is
available in the open source
version of the RStudio IDE.
So a number of different
ways that data scientists can
use R and Python to
deliver these wow
results to the rest
of the organization.
For the dev ops
and IT teams, using
these centralized
environments makes
it easy to support these common
tools for both R and Python,
and to operationalize both
languages without doubling
the work.
And by making both of these
languages easy to use together,
it helps data science
leaders really
optimize their team
for the people,
not for an arbitrary
choice of a single language
to better enable
collaboration within the team
and within their
stakeholders, and really
able to access these wider
talent pools to hire new data
scientists into their team.
And finally, for the
business stakeholders
in the organization,
ultimately, they
don't care about what the
underlying language is.
They just want to have
reproducible, accurate,
understandable, data
science insights
that they can use to help
make better decisions.
So by sharing this data
science work through platforms
like Connect, they can access
this up-to-date interactive
analyses and dashboards, or
get the information directly
in their email, so they can get
the answers they need in order
to make better decisions.
All of these capabilities are
supported by the RStudio team
set of products,
which together combine
to provide a single home for R
and Python data science teams.
Again, RStudio Server Pro is
the centralized environment,
allowing data scientists to
use R or Python to analyze data
and create these data products.
RStudio Connect is a platform
to publish the results
to make them make
available to business
users and other stakeholders,
using R or Python-based data
science products.
And RStudio Package Manager
to manage open source packages
for both R and Python.
One of the questions
that I saw in the Q&amp;A
was a question of
expressing pain
around how difficult it
is to manage packages
in the Python ecosystem.
And we've recently added
support for managing packages
from PyPI to RStudio
Package Manager
to help address that
exact pain point.
And I'll ask Sean to comment
on that in the Q&amp;A section.
RStudio is of course, used by
millions of people every week
using open source software,
things like the IDE
and the Tidyverse and Shiny,
critical source applications
that we create as part of
our open source machine.
But are also used by thousands
of active commercial software
customers, including over
half of the Fortune 100
and many well-known brands
such as the ones we see here.
We also have been
really gratified
to hear from our customers
via TrustRadius.com.
So if you are an
RStudio user, we
encourage you to
go to Trust Radius,
check out their RStudio profile,
read some of the reviews
that people have left there,
and add your own review,
because we read every
single one of these.
We try and respond.
And certainly, these
are one of the ways
that we hear from our users.
We've gotten great
feedback from our customers
on combining R and Python
in a single platform,
and how it helps them
collaborate among their team,
and to essentially
allow these teams
to, as the second reviewer says,
make use of their preferred
language for data analysis
so that they can create
and publish products via
RStudio Connect using both R
and Python to share with
their internal clients
and stakeholders, as the
third reviewer shows here.
Now we've talked a lot along
the way about our pro products,
but I want to
emphasize that our core
mission is to engage and support
the R and Python community.
And we do that in a
number of different ways.
The most important of course,
is creating the open source
software that our
users use every week.
But there are a number of
different ways we do it.
We support RStudio
Community site,
allowing R users
and Python users
to gather and ask
each other questions
and get answers to
those questions.
That's a great resource.
We do our annual conference.
This year it was a
virtual conference,
under current circumstances.
But that was just a
couple of weeks ago.
And we were very gratified
by the engagement there.
Check out our blog.
And there's a link
there to all the global.
All-- sorry.
All the videos from
RStudio Global.
Many different speakers
from all around the world.
Those are all free to watch.
We had a tremendous amount
of positive feedback,
both directly on social
media on that conference.
So I encourage you to
check out those videos.
Our education team is
focused to help support
the education of R.
We do a lot of train
the trainer
capabilities, providing
training materials, et cetera.
So if you're interested in being
a certified RStudio R trainer,
check out our Education page.
We're also supporters
of the R Consortium,
a multi-vendor group
to support and advance
the infrastructure
around the R language,
as well as a platinum
sponsor of Num Focus, which
provides a tremendous support
for the Python ecosystem,
among other projects.
And then finally, Ursa Labs--
we've been a supporter of
Ursa Labs from the beginning.
And Ursa Labs is
devoted to developing
cross-language capabilities
such as using the Apache Arrow
Project to provide
access, both within R
and Python to
those capabilities.
And it's important
to emphasize how
our open source and pro
products tie together.
Of course, it's
our core mission,
as I said, to
contribute open source
software to the community.
And we spend over half of
our engineering resources
creating this free and
open source software.
As the data science community
adopts open source software,
this drives adoption
within larger enterprises
and commercial customers.
These commercial customers in
turned by our pro products that
are focused on helping
scale out in operation lines
open source data science.
And by buying our pro products,
that provides RStudio the funds
so that we can sustain
our ongoing open source.
We call this idea
the virtuous cycle,
this idea that we're
supporting our mission
to deliver free and open source
software to the community
by selling the pro software to
the enterprise companies that
need those features.
So if you'd like some
more information,
we have a number of
different resources.
Again, these slides
and the recording
will be sent out within a
few days after the webinar.
RStudio.com/Python is your one
central portal to get to a lot
of this information.
We also did a blog post
recently on recapping
all the Python
related features we
added in both are
open source and pro
products over the last year.
So I encourage you to
take a look at this.
If you'd like to set up a
time to talk to us one-on-one,
you can use this URL here,
rstd.io/r_and_Python to learn
more, set up a meeting,
get some answers.
The webinar recording will
be available on our Resources
site.
If you'd like more
technical information--
and a number of the questions
and the Q&amp;A were looking
for more technical details--
check out some of these links
the reticulate package website,
as well as providing some
examples and a webinar
on that topic.
We also, on our
solution.RStudio.com site,
we've got a number of articles
providing deeper information
on how to integrate Python in
RStudio Server Pro and RStudio
Connect.
Again, those are all accessible
through the top level
RStudio.com/Python portal.
And for our community
site is a great place
to ask questions about R and
Python open source and pro.
Now going through the Q&amp;A,
the most popular question
was how to, as an R user,
how can I learn Python?
What would you recommend
to experienced R users?
I did a quick poll to
our education team.
And these couple of
books floated to the top.
Python for Data Analysis
or Python Data Science,
both of these books were
recommended by our education
team as being more
data first, as
opposed to programming first.
I will try and get a
few more recommendations
to add to the slide before we
share it with the participants.
SEAN: And I would
add to that, Lou,
as part of this
webinar afterwards,
we'll be sharing information on
the RStudio community page that
Rstud.io/RPyQA link, the link
that is currently bringing you
to the Slido with
all the questions,
will be redirected to
that community thread.
And we would actually
love for all of you
to give input to
answer that question as
well, because there's a lot of
diversity in how people learn.
We know these
communities are coming
from very different people in
lots of diverse backgrounds.
And so if you have something
that's worked really well,
we'd recommend replying
to that community thread.
We'd love to open source
the answer to that
question beyond us at RStudio.
LOU: That's a great point, Sean.
Thank you very much.
So with that Sean, is there
any particular questions
that you'd like
to kick off with?
SEAN: Yeah, absolutely.
I think one of the most
common questions was,
what parts of that demo are
available on the open source
side?
What parts are part of
the professional products?
And so apologies if I
didn't do quite enough
signposting there to delineate.
Essentially, s everything that
you saw inside of RStudio IDE--
so that visual editor of R
Markdown documents, the ability
to combine R and Python inside
of an R Markdown document,
selecting what Python
interpreter to use,
the Python objects in
the environment pane,
the Python reppel
even, those are all
going to be in that open
source desktop IDE, regardless
of what version you use.
And in fact, I would
encourage folks
to look at the re-articulate
website that talks a bit more
about some of the
options that I didn't
dig into for combining R and
Python in that open source way.
One of the questions asked, if
I just have a Python script,
can I use that in RStudio?
And the answer is absolutely.
That's something
that I didn't show,
but it is available in
the open source IDE.
So I'd encourage
folks to go there.
The things that were specific
to our professional products
would be the selection
of different editors
from that common workbench as
well as the deployment of work
to RStudio Connect.
I would encourage folks--
especially there
was some folks who
were saying I work at
a research institution,
or I'm teaching at
a university if I
would benefit from some of
those professional capabilities.
I would encourage
you to reach out.
A lot of the
professional products
we give away for free
if you're teaching,
and are pretty discounted
for research as well.
And so hopefully
that helps answer
that kind of common
question about what can I
do on my own today?
Everything inside
of RStudio i.e.
What would be part of the
professional products?
That would be anything
you saw in terms
of sharing or the
different editors
within the RStudio workbench.
LOU: Thanks, Sean.
So one of the other really
popular questions-- and I
alluded to it
earlier-- is this idea
of the challenges of package
management in Python.
And this is an area
I'm particularly
excited about because of the
recent addition of PyPI support
in RStudio Package
Manager, initially in beta.
Would you like to
comment on that at all?
SEAN: Yeah, absolutely.
So I would tend to agree
it is a bit of a mess.
That it's certainly is
kind of my experience.
Right now, the
RStudio sits on top
of the many Python management
tools that are available.
And so if you already
have a tool of choice--
you saw in my demo, I was
using a virtual environment--
if you're using something
like QANDA or Poetry
or PyEnv, the
RStudio it will sit
on top of all of those options.
And in fact, the kind of key
engine behind all of this
is an open source package
called Reticulate.
And within that package, you
can see the different functions
that help the IDE and R identify
what Python environment to use.
That's also something that
you'll see in the Options menu
that I mentioned,
where if you go inside
of RStudio IDE and
click Tools, Options,
basically any of those Python
environments, whether they're
from QANDA or Virtual Env
are going to be available.
Now that doesn't
necessarily mean
that the headaches go away.
And so one of the things that
we're working on in the future
is extending the support
for creating and managing
those virtual environments
from within the IDE as well.
And so you can look out
for that on the horizon.
And then, as Lou mentioned,
on the professional side,
if you think those headaches
are challenging as a single data
scientist, as a team of Python
users, that can often present
even more of a challenge, which
is one of the reasons why we're
investing for those commercial
teams in the package management
repository that supports
both R and Python
to help make that work
reproducible, to help
the IT folks say what
packages should be allowed,
as well as that time
travel capability
that I briefly showed.
So that's I think, a
long-winded way of saying we all
can commiserate with the
challenges in Python dependency
management.
We're going to continue to
invest and make it better.
But all of the kind of work--
we're standing on the
shoulders of giants here--
is available to you
from within RStudio IDE.
LOU: And I just want to add to
that another plug for RStudio's
own Alex Gold, who's also part
of the Solution Engineering
team, is going to be doing a
webinar in a couple of weeks
on the challenges of
package management
and how to address them.
We're going to be doing a
series of blog posts between now
and then, talking about the
package management problem.
So I encourage anyone
who's interested in that
to check it out.
Now Sean, I got a
favorite next question.
But anything that
you want to jump
to before I toss that one out?
SEAN: So there was one
question I really liked.
It's a very RStudio
question, which is asking,
what are the limitations?
And we try to be pretty
upfront with that.
So I'll just throw
out there I personally
use the RStudio IDE
when I'm combining
R and Python together.
I have friends who
use the RStudio
IDE for all their Python work.
I have other colleagues who use
the VS Code for their Python
work.
So kind of our common
theme is the tools
should be subservient to you
as a data scientist, and not
the other way around.
So pick what works for you.
But some of the
specific limitations
that you might run into that
we're investing to make better,
but you might hit
today are that kind
of creation of
Python environments--
I mentioned RStudio
sits on top of that,
but it doesn't really give you
tools yet today for creating
Condor virtual environments.
And then the other
limitation I would call out
is that the debugger
inside of RStudio
today is still
pretty R-oriented.
And so if you're
spending all day
kind of writing a long
Python application
and you are using the debugger
as a critical element of that,
I would tend to recommend
something like VS Code as maybe
a better option.
So that's my favorite question
talking about limitations.
What was your favorite question?
LOU: Mine was a closely
related question, which was--
I can't find it
now on the list--
but there was something
to the effect of
"can we now use
Python within the IDE
without a lot of shenanigans?"
So-- and my view on that
is the most recent release
RCO 1.4 has lowered the bar
of necessary shenanigans
considerably.
You want to comment on that?
SEAN: Yeah, I would agree.
As I said, I do have some
colleagues, especially
those who know R and
are learning Python
for the first time, can be
really nice to not introduce
yet another editor.
It can be challenging
when you're
trying to learn a new language
to also be learning a new tool.
And so I think if you're
someone who knows R,
that barrier of entry
is low enough now
that you can get started using
Python right within the RStudio
IDE.
Then if you want to graduate
to another editor, that's fine.
But at least you're learning
both those things at once.
But I kind of echo that
as well to educators
that are out there.
Someone asked, what
language should I teach?
Well, I think the
key is to teach
what you're going
to be comfortable
teaching to make sure that
your students have a really
effective data science
experience from day one,
that they're not stuck
fighting their tools
before they're able to
create their first plot,
whether that's a
matplotlib or a ggplot2.
You want to give them that
gratifying moment early on.
And it's my belief that
a lot of folks at RStudio
have done a ton of awesome
work to ensure that the RStudio
IDE isn't going to
present that hurdle
and isn't going
to fight students.
If you are a teacher interested
in using R and Python,
also do a quick shout out
to our RStudio Cloud, which
can reduce that hurdle even
further by allowing folks
to start writing code without
installing anything on day one.
LOU: And that's a good
segue to a question
I wanted to answer about
RStudio Cloud, which
is we had a question on whether
RStudio Server is running
on premises or in
the Cloud or what?
RStudio Server Pro-- typically,
most of our customers
will install or C
server themselves,
but where they install
it varies considerably.
It could be on-prem
and often is.
Or it could be in a virtual
private cloud on any
of the major cloud providers.
And so our customers do both.
We also have
marketplace offerings
for our RStudio Server Pro
on all three major clouds.
So you can search for RStudio
in those cloud marketplaces.
And that's a quick
way of spinning it up.
And then of course,
RStudio.Cloud
is, as Sean just mentioned,
is a way of getting started
with similar functionality
without having
to install anything and that
the host service purchases
on a monthly basis.
There was also a question on--
someone asking they have a
license for RStudio Server Pro.
Is the launcher
available, or does that
require the enterprise flavor?
The launcher is actually--
Sean, let me--
I thought I knew
the answer to that.
And I caught myself.
Could you clarify?
SEAN: Yeah, I would
say for those kind
of specific questions,
or if you have questions
about the professional
products, our sales team
is happy to help.
That sounds like a cheesy ad.
But I can tell you firsthand
at RStudio, our folks
that work with our
customers are all
in their own right, really
talented data scientists.
And they'll be able
to help you navigate
some of these questions.
And we'd be the first
to say you don't
need a professional product.
The open source stuff will work.
Or we can help you solve some
of the challenges that come up.
So I think that's kind of how I
would end things there, Lou, is
that we'd love for you to
dive into the resources, dive
into that community thread.
And then if you are encountering
some of the challenges
that we presented
throughout this webinar,
feel free to reach out to us.
And we are happy to help you
go through that path as well.
[MUSIC PLAYING]